السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره اعلنت الحكومه البولنديه مقتل
الشخصين جراء سقوطي صاروخين قالت انهما
روسيان في بولندا وقالت الحكومه ان
الصاروخين سقطاها على بلده بريميسيودوف
بمقاطعه لوبيسكي قرب الحدود الاوكرانيه
كما وصفت وسائل الاعلام البولنديه
الصاروخين بانهما طائشان
وذكرت رئاسه البولنديه ان الرئيس
الهولنديه
اجرى مكالمه مع نظيره الامريكيه جوبا ايضا
بشان التطورات الاخيره وعاقبه اجتماع عاجل
لمجلس الامن القومي البولندي قال المتحدث
امكانيه تفعيل الماده الرابعه من ميثاق
النيته التي تنص على حق العضوي في الحلف
في دعوه دول الحلفاوي واضاف المسؤول
البولنديا الحكومه قررت رفع درجه جاهزيه
الوحدات العسكريه
مراسله جزيره تامر الصمادي تامر التطورات
الابرز والاحدث
تطورات متسارعه محمد بالفعل اقطاب الحكومه
والدوله سياسيا واميا وعسكريا في حاله
اجتماع والعقاد دائم بعد هذا الحدث
المفاجئ والكبير الذي سيكون لهما بعده
وفقا لعديده المسؤولين هنا في وارسو قبل
قليل رويترز تنقل عن همم الرئيس البولندي
بان السلطات البولنديه تتعامل بحذر شديد
وهدوء شديد ما هذا الحادث وتنقل ايضا عن
الرئيس البولندي بان بانه لا يمكن حتى هذه
اللحظات تحديد المصدر المصدر الصاروخين
اللذين سقط به الفعل في احدى القرى
الحدوديه بين بولندا واوكرانيا ويقول ايضا
الرئيس البولندي بانه هذا الحادث يعني همم
لن يتكرر كما يقول في اشاره ربما قد يكون
الى تواصل بولندي روسي خصوصا في ظل
تاكيدات موسكو ونفيا تكون استهدفت الاراضي
البولنديه لكن في الحقيقه رئيس الوزراء
البولندي ايضا للتو تحدث بان الاستعدادات
العسكريه على اهبه الاستعداد الاستعدادات
العسكريه البولنديه وقالب بان القوات
النخبه يعني تكثف كما اا قال من مراقبتها
لتطورات الاوضاع واشار ايضا الى مراقبه
الدفاعات الجويه وايضا الاجواء المجال
الجوي البولندي بشكل مكثف وكانت هنالك
اتصالات مكثفه اجرها الرئيس البولندي مع
عدد من قاده دول العالم كان هناك اتصال
بينه وبين الرئيس الامريكي والنقل العديد
من المسؤولين هنا في وارسو بان الرئيس
الامريكي اعرب عن الاستعداده
للتحقيق في هذا
السلطات وزاره الخارجيه البولنديه تحدثت
قبل قليل بان الصوره الصاروخين مصدرهما او
هما من صناعه روسيه تحقيق ما زال متواصله
نعم تامر صمادي من ورسو شكرا جزيلا لك
وفيما نقلت رويترز عن مصادر الدبلوماسيه
قولها ان سفراء الناتو سيعقلون اجتماعا
تشوريا اليوم بناءا على طلب من بولندا قال
منسق والسياسه الخارجيه والامن في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بريل انه يبحث عقد اجتماعي
عن تنسيقي لقاده الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك
على هامشي قمه العشرين في بالي باندونيسيا
من جهتها نفات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
مسؤوليتها عن سقوط الصاروخين واتهمت وسائل
الاعلام البولنديه بالقيم باستفزازات
متعمداتهم
[موسيقى]
انت لما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير